foreign
a hundred random teenagers we would find
that while they all look different their
minds work in very similar ways one or
two however have Minds that are atypical
in a particular way they could be
diagnosed with autism this happens to
boys four times as much perhaps because
diagnosing them is easier
children and adults who are considered
autistic experience the world
differently because they were born with
various degrees of neuroatypical traits
most autistic children have more refined
senses and share a deep desire to bring
logic into their surroundings some seek
repetitive behaviors that follow
specific patterns and many appear to be
asocial and avoid eye contact autism is
not a disease and therefore cannot be
cured
since all our brains are different and
there is an endless range of nuances in
their architecture autism is defined as
a spectrum on one side of the spectrum
is high functioning autism also known as
Asperger's Syndrome these children are
highly intelligent and have extreme
abilities and interest in specific areas
in the middle are those with average
intelligence and some problems learning
new things in school on the far end of
the spectrum are children with severe
learning disabilities who may require
support in their daily lives
foreign
Teemo a young boy can help us understand
how living with a neurodivergent mind
can be his mum noticed early on that her
boy would avoid eye contact and that he
would often become upset if she hugged
him he never returned smiles and
engaging him in play with friends often
ended in a tantrum
his mother suspected something to be
wrong when Teemo still wasn't speaking
more than two or three words at a time
even after turning four years old she
sought help and Teemo was diagnosed with
autism spectrum disorder or ASD for
short
Teemo has an atypical perception when
reading books or watching movies teemo's
brain picks up and organizes the
information differently while his
neurotypical peers categorize things and
form schemas for example they identify
everything with four legs that barks as
a dog for Teemo each type of dog is
unique and categorized in teemo's mind
individually his attention to detail and
inability to generalize makes Teemo more
objective in his perception of the world
and less prone to a framing bias however
it also makes all sorts of new
experiences incredibly complex which is
why he loves to follow a rigid daily
routine to limit his sensory input
Teemo is highly sensitive his brain
amplifies whatever input it perceives he
hears everything and has a heightened
sense of touch however this superpower
makes situations where many people speak
simultaneously very challenging Teemo
hears everyone but understands nothing
the sensitivity to touch makes eating an
intense experience if a texture or
flavor is too much to handle Teemo won't
eat it also walking barefoot on wet
grass or playing in dirt overwhelms his
brain
[Music]
he has a fascination with logic Teemo
naturally looks for patterns that bring
logic into this world sometimes he also
tries to bring order into his own
behavior and ways of moving his body
when structured patterns are broken he
gets upset it freaks him out when
someone counts to eight but doesn't
continue to tan doctors call it an
obsessive compulsive disorder or OCD
Teemo experiences social disconnection
he has trouble connecting with others
because social settings overwhelm his
sensitivity and desire for order because
human emotions are incredibly complex
and don't follow a set predictable
pattern Teemo often finds himself
misreading situations and upsetting
people around him as a consequence he
avoids people and rarely makes eye
contact which doesn't matter that much
to him since most of the things other
people talk about are illogical
irrelevant and boring anyway
[Music]
for four years his mother had him
treated by a therapist who would show
him images of faces to help him learn to
identify feelings this meant he got
better at identifying facial expressions
and corresponding emotions however
personally he is still not very
interested in Reading faces or
establishing new social contacts
has two friends who share the same
interests and couldn't wish for more
[Music]
since teemo's autism is not an illness
we can treat but rather a different way
of him experiencing the world the
question remains whether we should try
to change him through therapy or accept
him for who he is
[Music]
so what do you think should we treat
children with autism with therapy or
celebrate them for who they are or
perhaps do both maybe it's not their
atypical minds but our stereotypical way
of looking at them that needs correction
to get a three-dimensional glimpse of
how an autistic girl experiences her own
surprise birthday party or to download
this video without background music
check the descriptions below or visit
sproutschools.com
[Music]
Sprouts videos are published under the
Creative Commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and
non-profit organizations can also use
them for training online courses or
designing new curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com
Sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference